why in the world is Apple making the
iPhone 15 plus when the 14 was such a
major failure well a lot of people are
saying they should not make this phone
at all but there's also a different
thought and this phone could actually do
way better this year which I will
explain when Apple announced the 14 plus
we were quite excited for it because it
was the first time that we had a large
screen iPhone that had a lower price tag
than the flagship Pro Max model now it
was a replacement for the 12 and 13 mini
many people asked for that phone for a
long time but when Apple gave it to us
the 12 mini did not sell well at all a
lot of people say it's because the
battery life was not good it was not
lasting all day but then the 13 mini had
a nice boost about two hours of real
world use better than the 12. now I I
personally really like the 13 mini and I
used it for quite a while but I couldn't
stick with it because the cameras
weren't as good as the Pro Models and
because the reception was lacking as
well and unfortunately the 13 mini sold
even worse than the 12 mini so Apple
decided to ax it get rid of it and give
us the complete opposite a larger
standard iPhone now the appeal was
supposed to be the large battery in this
phone without the extra power usage of
the pro Max which is supposed to give
great battery life but in the real world
that wasn't really the case and when you
compare them directly the pro Max had
that much nicer screen it has better
speakers it has the extra camera of
course you also have Pro motion there
are so many real world benefits that you
get for just two hundred dollars more
and because of that even after first
weekend the 14 plus disappointed with
sales whereas the 14 pro Max did way
better than expected Ming Chico gave us
info saying that the 14 plus actually
sold worse than the 13 mini and the
iPhone SE which was absolutely crazy so
after those tactic didn't work very well
turns out the people are just willing to
get into debt to get a new phone and to
get the Pro Models and the sales
compared to the pros were just terrible
I think a big part of that was the new
Dynamic Island which is a huge standout
feature visually on the phone that you
only get with the Pro Models and that
along with the other features was well
worth it for the extra 200 bucks and
Ross young gave his data saying that the
pro phones as far as panel shipments
that detracts are about 75 percent of
the sales whereas the 14 plus they
actually stopped production of the
screens because people were not buying
them because of that Apple is very
concerned and they were looking to
re-evaluate the 15 lineup to make it
work better but as it turns out they are
still making that 15 plus variant even
though some of us thought that they
could be axing this phone so why would
they do that well some of us thought
that's because they have a lot of extra
parts so they might as well use it but
the interesting thing this year with the
15 lineup they not only are going to be
changing the front of the device the
actual body is also changing with curved
edges so that means it's different
tooling and on top of that this year the
15 lineup is going to be getting a
dynamic Island now personally in the
past what I was thinking is that they
should just ditch the 14 plus size and
price point and ditch the s e model
which is very very outdated and instead
replace that with a mini because there
are still people that want to get a mini
but being so close in price with the
regular sized iPhone it just doesn't
make a whole ton of sense so if Apple
were to drop the plus replace it with an
SE that is basically the mini but with
some updated Parts I would get better
battery life with the newer chips that
would be a nice win-win and just keep
the standard 15 then you have the 15 Pro
and then you have the 15 Ultra a nice
clean lineup without a ton of phones
packing that in but now thinking about
it a lot further is seeing the failure
of the 14 plus why would Apple still
make one well I think there is a couple
of reasons now the first one we know is
that apple is gonna be raising the price
and the Pro Max or the ultra now well
that thing is going to start at twelve
hundred dollars now with the 14 plus the
price difference was not very large it's
a 200 price difference and then you
visually see the dynamic Island being
there it just didn't make sense to buy
that this year though with the price tag
going up we're having a bigger spread
between the prices and that should help
the 15 plus stand out more so now along
with that like I mentioned the dynamic
Island will be in this phone so it will
also look much more new much more fresh
something different than from what
people are upgrading to so if you're
spending the money you would want to get
something that has actually been
upgraded visually not just some parts
internally now the 48 megapixel sensor
was also a big deal for the pro phones
and this year a 48 megapixel is coming
to the regular 15 and 15 plus so users
are not going to have to choose to spend
more money to get higher quality photos
where the 14 plus was noticeably worse
with its 12 megapixel sensor now even
though the sensor is going to be uh
smaller than the pro phones you will
still have that extra detail now with
that we have another report that almost
80 percent of people are buying their
phones from carriers instead of online
sales through Apple's website now that
might seem weird but carriers have had
some killer deals some killer trade-in
offers and when people are going in
they're looking at the phones in front
of them and they're seeing that big
difference so I think now when they see
the 15 plus with the dynamic Island and
that lower price point
that will get a lot more people to
actually buy the phone and it may be
worth it for Apple to keep the 50 plus
and keep that size now just like the 12
and 13 mini I think this will be the
last year to test it out see if this
bigger price difference is going to help
and the refresh and see if they should
keep it for another year or two or if
the sales are still going to be as bad
as the 14 plus then they can ax it and
change up their lineup and maybe go with
the method of making a mini be the SE
out of 499 dollar price tag and
basically just thinning it out and just
keeping it more simple which I think
makes a lot of sense as well so you guys
let me know why you think apple is still
keeping this phone does this make sense
for them or should they just get rid of
it Go and click that Circle above check
out one of those videos right over there
there's been Max and I'll see you in the
next one
[Music]
thank you
foreign